hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's we're gonna be revisiting him
because today at cloak brand.com it's
the first day of the cloak naff collab
from shirts to sweatshirts to aprons to
security coats if you go to cloak brand
comm linked right down there in the
description you can check out some of
the five nights at freddy's inspired
cloak dear and I thought what better way
to celebrate than revisit the game that
started it all and I honestly have not
played it since I first played it a
little over five years ago there's been
many many many other five nights at
Freddy's games things songs probably a
theme park in the future but for now I
wanted to go back and I wanted to see
how this game was if it still had the
same magic if it still had the same
charm if I only thought of it through a
nostalgic light a door of nostalgia
hello absolutely necessary good night
who is thumbkin oh hi hello Barney now
the first thing I gotta say when I come
back to this is from when I first played
it I didn't really understand the layout
of the restaurant I was kind of confused
as to where everything was when I first
played it and having now gone through it
in 3d in VR in multiple different
incarnations of the game I can now see
exactly how this all pieces together and
I gotta admit it's creepy there is
something about this first one the
mixture of like the childish music the
fun like ambience the environment
the initial jumping into the pond that
is five nights at freddys without
knowing anything about the law or
nothing on its surface you take all that
away it's just a creepy ass game a
dumb-dumb need the bone they do this
like this idea it's out of order what's
in pirate Cove what what is this this
also spooky it just is you feel helpless
did you get enough of a sense to know
I'm here they come charging oh I can
actually hear their footsteps now I
don't think I ever heard their footsteps
before there's so much to this game that
is just so intelligently done I didn't
even know about that when I first played
the game I did not know about that man
it's so weird to be back it is so weird
to be back also one of the pieces that
one of the clothing is a spark from the
first one it's got the whole game the
gang's all here
spooky it's just like something about
the elements of this particular version
of the game was all in the unknown you
can't see it you don't get a good look
at him
like you know he's comin but you don't
really know what is going on there like
it's it's so many layers of unknown and
the fact that like when Freddy comes off
the stage you don't even see him besides
his freaking eyeballs it's frickin
eyeball oh oh god I'm good I'm good
okey good we're okay unless he's right
there no he's in here God just look at
the angles that were chosen for this
game got the first ones a masterpiece it
really is like it really is it's so
efficiently made it is such an efficient
experience it is exactly what it needs
to be and no more period and that's
fascinating that's fascinating Oh mind I
didn't know you could be active on the
first night wait what the hell did he
always be active on the first night I
didn't know
oh god that actually scared me no lie
that actually scared me
I can't believe it dad actually scared
me and I can hear the footsteps I'll
never listen to the Pacific War hi it
looks so friendly there it's so weird to
be back after all this time it's so
weird
and it's all here yah man it's just like
a triple oh I thought I heard foxy
charging down the way Oh Oh God and then
they start to get weird throughout the
rest of the night and don't get me wrong
the game's not perfect like I think we
can all agree the game is not perfect
today like it no game is perfect their
flaws have you pick it apart no matter
which way you go but as far as an
experience getting you into the mood
making you wonder about what the hell is
even going on I did it so good it did it
so good man how did I beat twenty mode
on this hey I'm gonna win maybe when I
first was playing and I didn't even know
to check foxy
I heard stiffy steps
I heard step you up ease
[Music]
if I'd have died on the first night I
would have been really upset with myself
or I'm gonna go with it but I don't know
let's just see what happens
Oh already Oh oh my god what they're not
I sure do thanks Scott thank you big
love big love big up man you know I
really uh oh I really got a commend
Scott for you know keeping this thing
going cuz even now like it obviously
it's lost its peak popularity but people
still look fondly back on five nights at
freddys I do I still do I still think
the game is well made and it's just like
kudos to Scott for being able to craft
such an experience from nothingness I'm
being very bad about power you know skip
step over your snippy step you step in
you stepping press this dip step
there's steps up your butt over you bear
step step in your butt
oh is that the dum-dum when I was ready
not step you thought you could catch me
with my pants down no I got my pants up
my brand new special pants available
clothing brand comm dad to buddy he's
still there are you still there aren't
you I heard this to be stupid
I heard the stiffest I'm being very bad
about power I forgot how tight the power
was I forgot how tight the power was in
the first game also golden Freddy in
this in this camera I don't know if I
could get golden Freddy to trigger but I
have no idea I don't know what what was
this special requirement it was it was
this poster would change I never knew I
got it accidentally I had no intention
of getting and I didn't even know what
it was I don't think many people even
knew about it I got I just so happened
to luck out and get it or unlucky out
and get it
hello I don't know if it's like a one in
a hundred chance er woo hi hello friend
how are you hey what's he doing there
buddy boo you step stepping you love a
stiff step and I know you you love stiff
stepping you step step you're way over
into my heart that's what you do and
being so bad about power
naughty naughty about power oh oh really
where'd you go where you going oh hey
buddy how you where did he go
how close was I to death there how close
oh very apparently just trying to see if
I can get golden Freddy come out to play
what was the requirement is it just
randomly pull up the camera one day and
easier it might be it might also be like
night restrictive it might be like only
third night could it happen sorry just
needed to scream hi bud look it's still
weird opening the camera and he's right
though oh boy you here know you're not
even well I'm about to win so come at me
bruised I'm ripped try me [ __ ] you're
too late you've activated my trap card
zone of literary tick tock time come on
time clock clock please clock bro please
block go clock
tik-tok I mean I think I'm just gonna
kind of go until I die Oh chica what are
you doing out oh hi oh my god hi
oh god no see you on the flippety-flip
inside out of a Hanuman tromo see you on
the flip flop flow but he flew how you
doin
it's getting real denied it in a warm
okay whoof b'doop b'doop b'doop
dippity-doo da zippers up Jimmy ma oh oh
no I forgot oh no where's oh no I forgot
you're actually creepy oh it is gonna
get real the night
I forgot you suck oh yeah I've been
doing hard cool at all oh my god see
it's actually creepy every part of it
it's tense and I don't like it I don't
like it at all I mean recreating this in
VR was really cool experience very
unsettling very uncomfortable to
actually see them walk by but the fact
that you can't see them walk by you look
at you big boy
I know you're there in the ladies
restroom there no no is silly-billy whoa
oh that's not good
what I okay cool hi I'm gonna run out of
power that is a certainty that is not a
guess that's absolute okay you're gonna
stay there for a while aren't you got a
dumb name daddy
q Q hey what the hell
sheesh okay thank you for that hey you
I'm gonna run up our oh wait where's J
him no that's that's nothing right
that's not nothing
that's nothing oh no it does get real it
gets real
I forgot was this game actually hard I
just kind of retro actively assumed
since I did 2020 mode I would still be
good at this game but I think I'm
goofing it oh my god am i goofing it I'm
using so much power how did this happen
to me how did I do this I'm goofing it
guys I'm goofing it okay finally gone
jeez guys I'm royally goofing it a big
goof energy right now oh god I goofed it
so goodly okay oh hey how you doing
there
God still startling damn you all right
this is how we're gonna do this oh
you're not there anymore okay good
you still there yeah you're still there
oh my god no 16% power oh that is the
opposite of good oh no oh no oh no okay
I got to conserve my power ah that's it
that's right I keep flipping up the
camera no wonder I'm using so much power
I forget the camera was actually a power
drain and it's all multiplicative [ __ ]
I mean poop oh that's not gonna help
either if I just okay I'm dead I'm
doomed
no no I'm doomed
no I'm
finally are you wait a minute who did
one now don't kill me I didn't mean I
literally it's not one it's not a goof I
didn't like all of our society 'it
freddy-boy
take your time there buddy bingo
buttinsky okay well turns out game still
hard turns out game is still hard ladies
and gentlemen that these five nights at
freddy's revisited after all these years
still still spooky I'm not gonna go out
of my way and just saying like it's it's
it's like this absolute masterpiece of
gaming and it's very influential and
it's very good and it's a very great
experience and and I think that's enough
that's all it's set out to be there's a
lot of people that held it to a standard
and because it was so popular that
they've judged it from all these
different angles but in all honesty like
the games so good the game is still
scary it does what it sets out to do it
gives you a feeling of helplessness it
puts you in a situation that is a
wonderful but weird world I love that so
thanks everybody for watching remember
cloak brand.com
link in the description cloak brand calm
that's clo a KBR ND calm go check out
the new cloak five nights at Freddy's
stuff we have on the website I imagine
it's going to sell out very very quickly
so go check it out and remember 10% of
the proceeds are still going to the
w-h-o solidarity fund to help fight
kovat 19 and the effects thereof so
check it out
once again cloak brand calm link in
description thank you to Scott Cawthon
for making a great game
I wonder if ice
to this day I'm pronouncing that name
correctly either way thank you everybody
so much for watching it was fun to get
back to five nights at Freddy's maybe
someday I'll revisit the other ones to
give a little play-by-play of what there
are after this many years so thanks
again now as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]